il reste trois semaines pour cotiser à
son reer pour l'année d'imposition 2010
9 la date limite pour cotiser cette
année c'est le 2 mars et le plafond de
cotisation est de 26 mai 500 $ 110 la
chapelle et planificatrice financière
bonsoir reér ou celi c'est souvent la
question que les gens se poser beaucoup
de gens ont de la difficulté à
distinguer les deux n'est ce pas
exactement probablement parce qu'elle va
dans les deux corps on peut utiliser les
mêmes placement mais ce sont des
véhicules dont le traitement fiscal est
différent ce qui peut amener une
confusion chez les investisseurs
donc le plus simple c'est d'identifier
la similitude dans les deux corps et art
et celi le rendement se fait à l'abri de
l'impôt donc dans votre portefeuille à
du revenu d'intérêts dividendes un
capital donc tout cela se fait en
franchise d'impôt par contre on pense au
retrait ou aux cotisations est le même
les différences sont majeurs donc dans
le code du reér on pense déductions
fiscales chaque montant qui est déposé
son réal va servir à diminuer le revenu
imposable les impôts à payer alors qu'au
niveau du celi c'est des investissements
qui sont faits avec l'argent des gens a
imposé dans aucun bénéfice fiscal
immédiat et au retrait effet miroir donc
si on retire ses billes libre d'impôt
mais sortir des investissements de notre
réel alors on va ajouter le montant du
retrait au revenu imposable de l'année
en cours de retrait
alors lequel doit tôt privilégie
maintenant la majorité des codes servant
indications financières encore il n'y a
pas de règle absolue mais dans la très
grande majorité d'écoles de ré à votre
mur et l'outil est privilégiée parce que
pour la majorité des contribuables
les revenus imposant va être plus élevée
pendant qu'on travaille qu'à la retraite
la majorité des gens pour la majorité à
la maison si on fait une image en clair
est encore un outil très puissant de
planification de la retraite et on
entend toutes sortes de mythes entourant
le reér j'entends dans mon bureau des
fois moi je compte je conclurai à
ça fonctionne pas parce que je vais
payer les impôts un jour donc ce que je
veux rappeler aux vosgiens fécamp
fiscalité un principe de base
donc oui on n'annule pas l'impôt mais on
l'a dit faire dans le temps donc on
s'enrichit personnellement au lieu de
payer la facture d'impôt immédiatement
on bénéficie d'un report d'impôt qui
nous paient qui nous permet de
s'enrichir et donc c'est c'est pertinent
même si oui c'est vrai que l'impôt ne
disparaît pas donc si par exemple vous
prenez votre retour d'impôts suite en
déduction real pour cotiser aux rayons
de vos enfants rembourser ddr tout payer
plus vite votre maison ou cotiser même
au celi donc c'est évident que ça va
fonctionner comme stratège
si vous êtes une famille avec jeunes
enfants rieurs aurait eu un bain
idéalement real et après eux
oui ensuite si on a un choix à faire on
va regarder ça dont le taux d'imposition
de la famille puisse situations
particulières mais c'est sûr que la
stratégie qu'on met en place le plus
possible avec les familles de classe
moyenne s'est cotisé à votre reér prenez
votre retour d'impôt et cotiser aux
rayons de vos enfants
pourquoi ont fait leurs erreurs aussi
c'est que au delà du rire c'est que la
cotation real faisant baisser le revenu
imposable va augmenter indirectement
toutes les crédits à aides
gouvernementales pour les enfants donc
de l'argent leur dépôt dans le compte de
banque des familles on aime ça en effet
si vous êtes un travailleur autonome
reér ou celi mais souvent dans le fond
c'est une situation qu'on peut voir chez
les travailleurs autonomes encore là qui
naturellement vont nous pousser au reér
c'est que les travailleurs autonomes
peuvent avoir des résultats plus
important qu'escompté en fin d'année si
on n'a pas soumis à ces d'acomptes
provisionnels pendant l'année une grosse
facture d'impôt qui nous attend après la
déclaration de revenus donc pour ces
gens là c'est une évidence qu'on va
préférer prendre l'argent là cotiser au
reér prendre la déduction fiscale et
puis au moins six effet d'annuler la
facture qui nous attend au printemps
alors dans quelles circonstances vous
pensez qu'on devrait se tourner vers le
compte d'épargné libre d'impôt le celi à
la base de ces lits a été
a été pensé pour inciter les familles à
revenus modestes à épargner donc ce sont
des gens qui étaient pénalisés par leur
erreur puisque il sera mans c'est avoir
un revenu imposable plus élevé à la
retraite et avaient moins d'être du
gouvernement donc ce cce ça a été
parfait pour les familles aux revenus
modestes et finalement avec le temps on
voit aussi que les gens qui maximise
déjà lauréats ont profité dans un
deuxième temps du celi et c'est des gens
des projets à court ou moyen terme
c'est une évidence qu'on peut utiliser
ces lits parce que les droits de
cotisation sont le son on peut lire
prendre l'année suivant le retrait donc
son retrait dans les airs on parle de
droits vis versus un celi ou là on
aurait très libre d'impôt et on peut re
cotisé l'année suivante et donc en ce
moment le montant est de 6000 $ pour
2020 quelqu'un qui n'a jamais cotisé
leçon à son celi serez à 73 1573 1500 $
dont il ya de la place pour beaucoup de
contribuables rien nada donc donc est ce
que je comprends que pour lily les
ménages à faibles revenus par exemple en
bas de 30 mille dollars de revenus
imposable par année il est préférable de
se tourner vers le scénic vers le reér
pour la majorité encore là je vous
invite à travailler avec votre comptable
ou un conseiller financier pour faire le
calcul précis selon un paquet de
facteurs mais de façon naturelle on
pressent tourner vers le celi est ce que
le réel est essentiellement un tube pour
leur retraite
mais c'est le citl c'est le véhicule le
plus approprié pour les retraites mais
c'est important de savoir que ces sommes
ne sont accessibles pour le contribuable
donc c'est un placement sans
investissement c'est votre argent vous
pouvez vous en servir de toutes les
façons donc dans le cadre du régime
d'accession à la propriété le retrait
dans le fond se fait sans pénalité pour
le régime non croisement
aux études supérieures également quand
vous avez le droit d'aller chercher dix
mille dollars pour retourner aux études
ou faveur de la formation continue mais
au-delà de ça en tout temps vossen sont
disponibles évidemment s'ajoute à votre
revenu imposable mais si vous avez une
transition de carrière si vous faites un
voyage autour du monde
en fait vous pouvez retirer votre équipe
si vous n'avez pas de revenus cette
année là on peut contrôler les dommages
au point de vue de la facture fiscale
voilà et je voyais aussi que le celi est
de plus en plus populaires même des
passes l'arrière mais en fait c'est que
c'est souvent les gens vont médecins à
court terme par contre petit bémol c'est
que comme penske ya très souvent faire
ce que je remarque que les gens
associent beaucoup celi les parkings
stable ou du revenu garanti donc c'est
très important que les gens identifient
les liquidités qui pourraient avoir
besoin à court terme et dans le fond
pour le long terme d'investir le marché
mardi cédant 1 610 la chapelle merci
beaucoup pour ses explications ce soir
merci bien